humans battle it out against aliens a
new virtual game on the internet Thomas
Friedman's company developed it he
managed to turn his love of fantasy into
a career his small development studio
competes against giants in the industry
his passion for play is evident this
bill says akala I love games and I love
the fact that I can develop them and
create worlds that provide fun for
hundreds of thousands of people that's
cool quit the company only makes online
games the staff of nearly 30 employees
have to get inside the heads of the
users to know what they want their
latest game is still in the test phase
but it's already online the company
invites feedback from users for example
they don't like the way the walls look
so game designer Christian patata makes
changes casal as what was calm he's also
the man who irons out any errors didn't
crush it this tutorial has the wrong
image which is misleading to the user
fix the Buddha Texan image don't match
so that needs to change but that's a
quick jog thinking that could fix this
is kind of always ought to go haha feel
how often do games need to be changed um
make changes nearly every day a huge
investment considering the games are
initially offered for free Friedman has
invested millions he's been in the
business for 25 years and says you can't
get anywhere without taking risks are
the most beautiful when you release a
game it doesn't mean the people all over
the world are going to jump on it and
you become a millionaire often gets one
is what's that for it's like in the
music industry if you put out a hit you
can get rich but very few games become
hits there are no guarantees on danica
happy to feel he's developed 15 games in
all and only two of them posted losses
not a bad average he's now passing on
his experience to younger develop
pulse is not the most important part
they fight from there on our panel
members today he's visiting a new
company in mülheim the founders are
developing their first game they too are
working only with the internet online
games are popular with users they don't
have to install any software can start
straightaway and at first it's all free
stuff up to the bong jong kook done free
games are the general trend most players
would never pay for this game but it
allows you to have a far greater
audience you reach far more people these
patent feel identification and players
are used to being able to play for free
at least to start with defecated
symanova home the company offers extras
which do cost money these could be more
time for example or better equipment
they make the game more exciting they
might cost just a matter of sense but
all you need is a few thousand users and
you're in business as a supplement I
can't predict what's going to happen in
two or three years and that's exciting
is google glass going to bring out a
better games platform and everybody's
going to start running around with
digital glasses so that i can start
making games for that I think that'll
come oh cool does that worry you I know
it's fun if I was worried I wouldn't be
in this job doing something more
predictable like carpentry or the civil
service talk by Z mahadeva banda the
real cake thomas friedman and his
company are playing against real
competitors are the game developers and
that makes the creation of online games
really fun yeah